[Music]
on this friday night preparing for
protest
[Music]
a trucker's convoy rolls into the
nation's capital the demonstrations this
weekend will be unique
fluid
risky and significant the warning from
police and the demands from protesters
every single person that parliament
resigns a new omicron what we know about
the sub-variant spreading rapidly around
the world
the fast and the fearless you're going
faster than you can drive your car and
you can do that at age 14. meet the
canadian teens going for gold in beijing
national with donna friesen reporting
tonight jeff semple
we're here to free canada this is not a
fringe
a look at the fast-growing crowds in
front of parliament hill some of the
first to arrive ahead of this weekend's
protest against the government's vaccine
rules and many more are on their way at
least six separate convoys more than a
thousand vehicles according to police
coming from across the country
good evening and thank you for joining
us ottawa police are asking residents to
avoid downtown this weekend and to
expect gridlock the protests organizers
are offering assurances that
demonstration will be peaceful but the
police chief also had a stark warning to
anyone who breaks the law our chief
political correspondent david aiken has
been tracking all of those developments
for us david
well jeff police were telling us today
they're going to do everything they can
to keep this peaceful this weekend but
police are anxious about what's to come
the demonstrations this weekend will be
unique
fluid
risky and significant
these demonstrations are national in
scope
they're massive in scale
unfortunately they are polarizing
in nature
those already here on parliament hill
well they have any number of grievances
everybody they only have two demands and
it's either trudeau steps down or the
mandates are lifted across canada we
want love that's why we're here we want
love and freedom for everybody every
time we turn around there's another law
of regulation
and we're just tired of being told what
to do every single person that
parliament resigns or they end all of
this narrative and drop it that's what i
want to see
there are six convoys each from
different parts of the country some are
already here some are on the way police
have been in close communication with
convoy captains all with the aim of a
peaceful demonstration but police are
worried about parallel protests counter
protests and external actors going
online and inciting violence meanwhile
some in the trucking industry are
worried it's a little bit disheartening
when these people are
protesting the way they are and the
protests themselves are disrupting
supply chains it has the the chance to
give the industry a bad perspective
and one of the big unknowns is how big
this protest will get police say they
know of 250 trucks that are here or are
on the way another 1 000 personal
vehicles here or on the way more than
enough to shut down parliament hill now
police stress time and time again that
they really do not know how many trucks
and people will come how long they will
stay and most importantly whether or not
they'll remain peaceful jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david the
protest organizers say the convoy's
substantial gas bill is being covered
with the help of a gofundme campaign
more than seven million dollars has been
raised in just two weeks so far more
than 93 000 donations have been made
making it gofundme's top fundraiser in
canada right now eight of the top 15
donations are anonymous including the
largest of 25 000 made just yesterday
gofundme had put a hold on the funds
until a clear plan for the money was
presented but the company now confirms
that one million dollars has been
withdrawn and gofundme says it will work
with the organizers to release the rest
of the money
and as that convoy condemns canada's
vaccine rules pope francis is speaking
out over his concerns about the spread
of pandemic disinformation
speaking today with catholic media the
pope condemned what he called the
distortion of reality based on fear over
covet 19 vaccines he added that access
to accurate scientific information is a
human right the pope's message comes as
some catholic media outlets have been
shut down by social media giants such as
facebook for spreading covet 19
disinformation
federal health officials were asked for
their thoughts about that convoy heading
to ottawa during a briefing this morning
and the health minister attempting to
use the convoy as an analogy stressed
that vaccinations are the best way to
protect against covid19
the convoy of which we should be
speaking is a convoy of everyone being
on board
knowing that the enemy is not
vaccination the enemy is corvid 19. and
the best tool to fight this enemy is to
be
vaccinated global news has confirmed
that prime minister justin trudeau is
isolating because one of his children
tested positive for covid19 the prime
minister began his five-day isolation
period on thursday he says he feels fine
and has tested negative
canada's top doctor says it appears the
omicron fueled fifth wave of the
pandemic has peaked dr theresa tam says
average case counts dropped by 28
percent compared to last week wastewater
surveillance and poverty rates are also
trending down but tan says cases of
severe illness and death are still
rising and there are growing concerns
about that new sub-variant of omicron
which appears to be picking up speed
here's abigail beeman on what you need
to know about ba 2.
ba2 another type of omicron no one is
really surprised as long the virus
continues to multiply new mutation will
hold guarantee that is the lifestyle of
the virus but this one is a sub-variant
so what does that mean the regular
omicron we've been dealing with is ba1
you can kind of think of them as sisters
in a family that they're related to each
other they have a common parent that
they both were derived from but they're
slightly different from each other ba2
has different mutations and experts say
we don't yet know enough about it it's
picking up speed in places like the uk
india and denmark where it's the most
dominant strain we've detected it since
november canada's top doctor says more
than a hundred cases have been
identified here and public health is
monitoring closely international data
suggests that it could potentially have
an increased
advantage on spread but that doesn't
seem to be any specific increase in
hospitalizations or
the severe outcomes it may be more
subtle but it needs to be watched and
needs to be studied the sub-variant has
picked up the nickname stealth omicron
which this virologist calls misleading
calling it the stealth variant implies
that it somehow
acquired
sneaky super powers that it doesn't have
if you have ba2 a pcr test will still
tell you you're covet positive it's just
not able to detect the specific sub
variant sequencing is needed for that
for most people though
i don't think they really care which
particular sublineage of the omicron
variant they're infected with because it
doesn't really change what they need to
be doing next at friday's briefing dr
tam stressed that while we may have seen
the peak of this wave across the country
coming down the other side still means
many infections and ba2 could be part of
that descent abigail beeman global news
ottawa
turning now to the crisis over ukraine
the pentagon says the buildup of russian
troops along ukraine's border is unlike
anything seen since the cold war the u.s
secretary of defense believes that
president vladimir putin hasn't yet
decided what to do next and he's again
urging the kremlin to stand down
he can order his troops away
he can choose dialogue and diplomacy
whatever he decides
the united states
will stand with our allies and partners
washington has stoked fears of an
imminent invasion but keeve is
downplaying those concerns today
ukraine's president spoke to reporters
including our europe bureau chief
crystal gamansing about the situation in
the country
as ukrainian soldiers tested their
weapons their president shot down
criticism he's minimizing the threat of
war to his people it's not that we're
acting as if it's not the highest level
of threat we are getting prepared for
their high
threats
but we understand the reality that we
are in vlodimir zielinski says his
country is ready to defend itself should
the kremlin order its soldiers to move
into ukraine and he urged western
countries not to create panic when it
comes to the threat of war russia again
said it's not their country's objective
if it depends on us the russian
federation there will be no war
a line zelinski outright rejects they
can do everything they have a powerful
army why do you need drills to happen
specifically here it's not just russian
troops ukraine is contending with
can you share any information about any
of those sort of physical or cyber
attacks that have been identified or
prevented
so we
have had quite a number of cyber attacks
we have prevented
those and
we did manage to restore
and
recommission many
websites of our government
institutions
in terms of the physical attacks i think
the strong how strong is our team is
strongest that we can preemptively
prevent knowing that there could be
casualties if we don't
western leaders are working to try to
defuse tensions in a phone call friday
russian president vladimir putin told
francis emmanuel macron that the u.s and
nato had not addressed russia's key
concerns we are working hard
for the best
peaceful political solution but we also
prepared for the worst the canadian
government says it's doing what it can
to support ukraine the defense minister
is expected to travel to the country in
the coming days
jeff crystal gomezing in kiev ukraine
thanks crystal
and coming up a little later we'll
examine the complicated history between
russia and ukraine that led to this
point and the long road to recovery an
exclusive look inside kovit 19
rehabilitation hospitals
take a look at this a terrifying commute
for drivers in pittsburgh after a
two-lane bridge collapsed today injuring
10 people rescuers repelled 46 meters
and formed a human chain to reach those
trapped in a bus at the bottom of the
ravine five other vehicles were involved
but incredibly no one was killed the
snow-covered bridge buckled just hours
before u.s president joe biden arrived
in pittsburgh to promote his trillion
dollar infrastructure plan he toured the
scene this afternoon a 2019 inspection
of that bridge had warned it was in poor
condition
health officials are closely monitoring
covid19 hospital admissions as a measure
of the severity of the pandemic but what
that number doesn't capture are the
patients discharged from acute care beds
but who are still too sick to go home
they're sent instead to a rehabilitation
hospital on the new reality this weekend
carolyn jarvis gains exclusive access
inside those hospitals and she joins us
now with more carolyn
jeff this isn't the front line nor is it
capturing headlines but rehabilitation
hospitals like this one are crucial in
helping the sickest covet patients get
home
here at toronto grace health center
they've had to rewrite the playbook for
a new type of patient they've created an
entire unit for patients who are on
ventilators long term to ease the
pressure off acute care hospitals
they've also hired 170 new staff
including those with icu expertise
we spent months chronicling the journey
of one patient here patty romero who
nearly died of covid through rehab she
re-learned how to breathe on her own eat
again and after three months take her
first steps again you're gonna go on
three one
two three good
you're doing well okay we're right
beside you
not going anywhere okay
it's amazing
toronto grace isn't the only rehab
hospital of this kind across the country
there are many of them but as one doctor
said to us these are the invisible
patients of the pandemic
i don't think that a lot of people
understand what these rehabilitation
hospitals do or that they even exist
it's the hospital you don't know until
you need it
and as we also learned it takes a team
of specialized health care professionals
rallying behind a single patient to help
them get home
jeff
thanks carolyn
in her exclusive story carolyn will
introduce us to three covid rehab
patients who share their raw stories of
recovery you can watch the new reality
this saturday at 8 p.m on global
how did we get here just ahead the long
road that led to the current crisis over
ukraine
welcome back the relationship between
ukraine and russia is complicated
russians like their leader vladimir
putin see many similarities between the
two countries but opinion polls show
ukrainians want to remain independent
eric sorenson has more on the history
behind the current crisis
this is the neighborliness russia wants
belarus welcoming russian troops weapons
and the russian defense minister
in ukraine troops prepare for the
opposite purpose
to repel the russian military
just 40 kilometers from the russian
border in kharkiv ukrainians are
remarkably calm but defiant
no no way he'll leave says this man if
he must he will defend his city
ukrainians view their history through
the lens of russian oppression under
stalin and others for many russians the
two countries are bound by culture
language and geography
vladimir putin has called russians and
ukrainians one people this is a myth
that was created to support uh russian
imperial ambitions they had to justify
their claims to ukrainian territory for
most of the 20th century ukraine was the
western bulwark of the soviet union 15
republics led by russia that made up the
largest country in modern history seven
warsaw pact nations in eastern europe
provided a further buffer to the nato
countries in the west
but after the soviet union dissolved in
1991 the soviet republics became
independent the former warsaw pact broke
apart those countries and three soviet
states in the baltics have since joined
nato russia is determined not to let
ukraine be next the build-up of the
united states and nato's forces next to
the russian borders is of great concern
russia has always seen nato as an
organization that was formed with one
purpose which was to contain russia in
many ways this is president putin going
back to
address the outcome of the cold war to
rewrite the rules of the european
security order
returning russia to its glory days
depends on ukraine and its strategic
access to the black sea and to europe
the takeover of crimea and the incursion
into eastern ukraine in 2014 may have
been a prelude to what's happening now
staging the russian military in belarus
and along ukraine's eastern border prior
to a possible invasion that could even
encircle the capital kiev i believe
putin sees himself in the history books
look at what happened with belarus with
kazakhstan now ukraine is the biggest
chunk and the most important part in
this puzzle
if ukraine is the crucial piece of the
puzzle it's not the only piece other
former soviet states are watching and
worrying like georgia the faith of
ukraine has a lot to actually say about
the fate of other small nations in
eastern europe and particularly in the
vicinity of russia if putin's aim is to
ensure russian security its neighbors
believe they will pay the price to
achieve it eric sorensen global news
next meet the young canadian women
looking to slide their way to a podium
finish in beijing
canadian athletes have started arriving
in beijing for the winter games five
delegates were just placed in covid
protocol though it's unclear if they
tested positive despite all the extra
pandemic restrictions and rules some
athletes say it's a dream they're not
willing to give up mike charley spoke to
two canadian teens preparing to make
their olympic debut
for the uninitiated the luge run is 40
seconds of terror
well consider 18 year old natalie
corliss and her 19 year old canadian
luge teammate trinity ellis among the
initiated few speed demons who live for
it it's
nothing like you're ever going to
experience anywhere else you're going
faster than you can drive your car
um and you can do that at age 14.
so
it's pretty cool to you know tell your
friends about they were around 10 years
old and fearless when they picked up the
sport which probably explains why
they're so non-plus about the speeds
kind of at this point in
like my sliding career it's almost
i would say
uh peaceful
in some ways which sounds kind of crazy
because you're going 130 kilometers an
hour
neither really remembers the vancouver
olympics but they still consider
themselves children of those games
because the only operating lose track in
the country is in whistler which they
now call home
years of two-a-day training sessions has
led them to beijing where they'll be two
of the 15 teenagers on a canadian
olympic team with 215 athletes the road
to beijing hasn't been easy which is why
even with pandemic restrictions they
never gave a second thought to not going
like to me this could be a once in a
lifetime opportunity right it's a really
big
thing to turn down and i have a lot of
trust in um
like all the people in charge they're
professional athletes yet they're still
teenagers who laugh when their friends
jokingly mispronounce loser yeah all the
time
say more of my like friends at home and
stuff they're all so eager and anxious
to experience their first olympics i
cannot wait to just be able to
open the bag get to put all my stuff and
say like this is it i am here
of course they are they're losers
spelled with a g and they're winners
mike dralet global news toronto
those losers sure look like winners
looking forward to seeing them in action
that is global national for this friday
i'm jeff semple tonight's your canada is
the aurora borealis over yellowknife in
the northwest territories there are
beautiful spots all over canada so
please email us yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching have a great night
[Music]